- [Kelly] How are you doing?
- I'm so good.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah, I'm great. How are you?
- I think about you often, this is why.
We read Sparkella so much.
- [Channing] I'm so sorry.
- [Kelly] No, we do.
My kids always wanna read it and I'm like
there's other books in the
library, but we read it so much.
Anyway, your your
children's book is a hit,
how's your daughter doing?
- Thank you. Thank you very much.
She's so good. My daughter's great.
Like we read the book a lot as well.
- [Kelly] Yeah
- I mean like it's so it's,
it's still in my house
even though like, she
basically helped me write it.
So she,
- I know.
- She just likes calling me a poop
and a poopy snail.
- Glitter poop
- [Channing] Like glitter poop.
- I read it.
So it wasn't a lie.
So wait, so magic Mike
three it's happening, right?
- Yes
- I heard that it's happening.
- Yeah, yeah
- You were trying keep it from us.
- I really did not.
- You were trying not to do it.
- I, I, you know, if
I'm, if I'm moving here.
- Oh my gosh.
- If I'm, oh God,
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
- [Channing] No, No, don't put that up.
- I would put that, if I
worked out and looked like that
I would put it up everywhere.
- Trust me.
That might be the reason
why I didn't want to
do a third one is because
I have to look like that.
- Is it, so you don't work
out regularly all the time.
- No, but it's, it's hard to look like.
Even if you do work out,
to be that kind in shape
is not, it's not natural.
- Do you have to eat like so well?
- Yeah, you have to, well is not even
that's not even healthy.
You have to starve yourself.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- I don't think when you're
that lean it's actually health
- Health is dangerous, that's why.
- [Channing] It's true.
New public service announcement folks.
Health is not good for you.
- This is why I don't work out.
I am just trying to save people here.
No, but what is it like
getting into shape for that?
Like is it that kind of hell?
- Yeah. I mean, I, which
truly, I don't know how
people that work in nine to
five actually stay in shape
because it's my full-time
job and I can barely do it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But it is.
You work out twice a day
you have to eat completely
right a certain time.
It's a, it's a specific thing.
- [Kelly] It's a talent to
be able to do that as well.
Even in like, when I
have like vacation time,
I'm like, this is the time.
- [Channing] Yeah.
- I'm gonna do it.
No, no, I don't do it.
- I fluctuate like almost
I, it was a lot more when I was younger
but now I can't, I can't get it off.
So, as easy. So now I'm
fluctuate like 15 pounds,
but I used to fluctuate like 30 pounds.
- [Kelly] Age is not fun.
- No.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And why? When it takes like,
I don't know, two months to
get really lean, but in like
three days you can lose it.
- You can ruin it.
- It's gone. I was like,
what, what happened?
- It was just a weekend.
- [Kelly] What's the
thing that you miss most?
- [Channing] Yeah.
- Like what's the thing you miss most?
- The thing I miss most
probably is like salt.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- Like when, like when you
need to get really close to the
like the day where you gotta
be butt naked on screen.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And, and it lives enough for me.
- [Kelly] Those, those, those
days aren't for everyone.
- No
Salt is just like, you
know, it goes, you just
everything just tastes like I don't know,
tastes like water. It's nothing.
- [Kelly] See, I'm a sweet person.
I, can't not like when they're like, oh
you're not gonna be able
to have sugar on this diet.
I'm like, oh, I'm out.
- Oh, see you later.
- I mean I like monk fruit.
I like salad.
I like all the things you can like do.
But every once in a while,
I just want some good,
like Ben and Jerry's so.
- Do you have to finish every
meal with like a sweet taste?
- [Kelly] No.
No, but I don't.
But what I crave though,
every time I've done
like a hardcore thing is always like cake.
- [Channing] Yeah.
- Chocolate cake,
- [Channing] Cheat days.
- I want it right now.
- Yeah.
I was actually at doing a,
doing press doing a junket and
and so I was like, I'm
gonna give myself a treat.
And I ate like an entire two
pieces of chocolate cake.
And I was just like,
- [Kelly] Dam straight.
- But it was, as soon
as it hit, like my brain
I felt like immediately sick,
it was euphoria.
And then immediately sick.
I, I was just like, why did I do that?
- [Kelly] I know it's so bad for us.
- Yeah. It's terrible. But it's delicious.
- But it's so good.
- Why are the most delicious
things this horrible way?
- I know. That's just Satan.
So I,
so I hear the new Magic,
the Magic MIke movie has more
of a female point of view.
- Yeah
- [Kelly] Is that true?
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Okay.
I'm interested.
- Yeah. So like the first two movies were
about men and kind of
weirdly made for women.
So they were like these
feathered fish types.
- [Kelly] Yeah, we thank you.
- You're welcome. We thank you as well.
- It was a public service, I feel.
- Still trying to do our part really.
- [Kelly] Pleasing people, doing Gods work
- Equal opportunity, objectification, yes
Yeah. And I was like
- But they're fun as well.
I don't actually, just
as that, they're fun.
And it's talent to be
able to dance like that.
- Look, we're just trying
to do, do our duty.
- I agree, I agree, but
what's the female perspective.
How does that play?
We, I really wanted
like a central character
that it was at least an
equal, if not more, even more
of a central character
of, of Mike, you know?
Because it, it, it should
be told at some point
through a female's perspective,
like what the world is
and how sex or freedom or
relationships kind of like evolve
around her world.
So we're gonna go to
London and there's gonna
Thandiwe Newton
- [Kelly] Oh, it's getting fancy.
- I'm not sure if I can say that
but Thandiwe Newton is gonna be our,
- [Kelly] oh my God.
- [Channing] Our lead.
So,
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh, oh my gosh
I'm excited. I have to say
Have you, this is my first question.
Cause when I watch this movie,
this is my first question.
I have actually taken showers with my dog.
- [Channing] Oh yeah.
- Because it's easier.
- Yeah, totally.
- Because he gets to so
dirty, like at the beach
or something or a skunk got him once.
And I was like, look, this is too much.
So I was just so I, yeah
I've taken showers, but not,
not a bath, but showers.
- The skunk thing is such a menace.
Like they're menace because like my dog
before the dog I have now Lulu
which would kind of inspired this movie.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- She was obsessed with skunks
And like, I think there was
about four or five years
that her mouth never
didn't smell like a skunk.
And there was like skunks living
in our backyard and it was just
- Me too.
- I was like, I'm gonna kill
every one of those skunks.
- [Kelly] I know there were three of them.
There were three of them.
They kept attacking my dog.
My dog just kept wanting
to play with them.
- [Channing] Ah God.
- And every time he got sprayed
and I was like, dear God
- [Channing] Your whole
house smells, you have to do
like the the weird
concoction with tomato juice
and all this stuff.
- [Kelly] Dude.
I did all the things that
everybody told me, but I just
I was dying when I watched this movie,
and I was like done that, I've been there.
- Yip, yip, fully.
- Well, everybody Channing's
new movie is called Dog.
- [Kelly] If you didn't
know, it's amazing.
You've gotta see it.
The one thing I love about
the movie I have to say is
and I wrote this in your card
but I love that you like
laugh and it makes you think.
- Yeah.
- You know and because there's
some serious subject matters
in there and it's also
just such a great story
and people relate to it and
you just feel all the feels.
- Yeah.
- I love a movie that
takes you on that ride
like emotionally.
And it perfectly does that.
- Fully. I mean, we, we got
inspired from, I lost my puppy.
Like my first, like, you know,
I had dogs all growing up
but like my first dog was this dog Lulu.
And like, she was like my shadow.
She didn't like want to
do anything that didn't
have me involved and, and lost her.
We went on a road trip
and then literally like
two days later she passed.
And so we were gonna tell that
story about a guy that went
on a bucket list, sort of
like journey with his dog.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And that, that story.
And sadly, like, you know, we were like
who wants to actually see that?
And we don't want people
like leaving the theater
wanting to kill themselves,
- [Kelly] Yeah
- But it's relatable as well.
Because that happened to me as well.
- Truly it, yeah, it is.
- But I like this movie better
- Truly though, because
like it, dogs are joyful.
- They bring so much joy.
- [Kelly] Yeah,
- We wanted to tell a joyful story.
And, and so we, we decided
to tell a different story and
and something that had
a lot more hope in it.
And we landed on this story
and, and you know, the
these two crazy characters end
up just like kind of biting
and fighting each other,
all, all down this road.
- And they're going
through their own stuff.
That's, what's kind of cool.
- They're bit mirrors for each other.
- Exactly. You're both kind of
going through similar things
but in different ways and
it's dog's perspective
your perspective and how y'all kind of
your relationship is
hilarious, but it's also cute
and sad and all the
things, it's all the feels.
It's so good.
But the last time that you were here
you premiered the trailer for Dog
and you brought your co-star
and I remember he very much like DVDs.
- I'm sorry.
- Let's see this.
- [Channing] She likes to eat this.
This is Dog, our movie
that we have coming out.
- She eats your movie.
- Yes. She eats the movie.
So we're just gonna let her eat it.
- Oh God. I love it. I love it.
Get it, just tear it up.
Tear it up.
- I know, I know.
- This is how I am with chocolate.
- Welcome to making a dog movie.
I was so worried. I was
like, cause you know, dogs
especially those kind of dogs.
They're they're just so intense and
- Highly trained ones.
- Highly, highly trained, and
they're there, there are a lot
of energy.
- [Kelly] I had one.
- And I'm just happy
she didn't scratch you.
- No, I had, I was so prepared though.
I had Cairo, we had a Doberman for years.
- [Channing] Cairo's a cool name
- He came with that name.
He was beautiful.
He was of Doberman.
And he was trained by like SWAT.
Like he was a trained dog.
Like, and I would get a fearful
though, because of if he was
around other people
because he was trained to
protect our home and us.
So I'd get, people would come
over and they'd be like, so
- They'd go to hug you and you'd be like,
oh let's do hug in the other room.
- Like he's like all of a sudden you see
in the corner just like eyeing you.
It's like, yeah.
Yeah. It was like, but I
love, I think it's really cool
because those dogs are so important.
I also love that y'all are
showcasing that in the movie.
They're so important to military.
- They really really are.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. I,
- They're like best friends.
They are your, the comrades,
like going out there,
doing it with them.
- There's such a thin
line between human and,
and like canine.
And, and in our experience, we
did this documentary for HBO
about war dogs and they're
really high level canine dogs
and they're handlers.
And what we got to see was
that these soldiers that are
like the ultimate at
warriors, they're, you know
very little like emotion.
They don't let you in very much.
They've been taught and kind
of probably just were already
predisposed this way to
like really compartmentalize
their emotions and not
really kind of, I don't know
not let you in not be vulnerable.
Yeah. But then all of a
sudden you'd see this like
this like big, tough guy that's you know
like the literal picture
perfect of a soldier.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Turned into like reduced
to like baby talking
and this dog,
- [Kelly] How you were with the bath.
- Exactly. You so cute
And you're just like what?
That's not the same
person and they just have
an access point, I think.
That that not a lot of other things
can do for these men and women.
- [Kelly] I love dogs.
I'm like, I love all animals,
but I'm such a dog person.
I grew up with them.
Did you grow up with them?
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah
Yeah. My whole life outside
dogs inside dogs often.
- I, I love this though.
You, you spoke about this
before, but you co-directed
the film, right?
- [Channing] Yes.
- Is this your first time
doing something like that?
- First time, first time.
- [Kelly] Was it scary?
- It was
- I feel like its a lot of pressure.
- It was, it was,
it was a lot harder than
I, as you can imagine
than than I expected it to be,
we thought it was a simple movie.
You know, it was me
and a dog and what not.
But at the end of the day, I
probably won't direct again,
if I'm gonna be in the movie.
I'm in every frame of the film
and to try and like direct,
you don't have any time to
actually go watch what you've done.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So it's, it's a little frustrating, but
- [Kelly] And are dogs like kids?
Like, you know what I'm saying?
Like you think it's gonna be great.
And then it's like, whoa,
this is hard to control
- The dog doesn't care what the story is.
Like he doesn't care
about, he's like, oh yeah
what's going on with your like whatever.
What do you want me to do?
He's like,
- [Kelly] I don't wanna go over here.
- Gimme the treat.
Like I just gimme the
but, but yeah, you're
you're kind of, I don't
know, cornered into like
you just need the dog
to like walk over here
and sit down and, and that's
that's you could do one task
but if you started getting,
like asking two things
you now were in like no man's land really?
- Yeah. And there there's so many people
around the dog, so yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah. That's why Brita
was so kind of crazy.
She'd never been around
people clapping and,
- [Kelly] I, oh wait, a band
We had everything going.
- [Channing] It was going off.
- She was like wow
- [Kelly] What kind of speed am I on?
- This is a party let's ride.
- She's so cute though.
So do you, I don't know.
Do you consider working
with animals as a career?
Like would you, did you ever do that?
Cause I think you like animals a lot.
- I do like animals.
- Would you ever been like a vet?
- [Channing] I could have done.
I, I was, I worked at a puppy
kidding nursery in senior,
my senior
- You're adorable. What?
- It was just like cleaning up poop.
I don't know how adorable it was.
- [Kelly] Oh yeah. Well I,Yeah.
I worked in a zoo and they put me right
by the monkeys and all
they did was poo all day.
- [Channing] Yeah.
Were they throwing it?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
So I was near poo a lot as well.
They did, but I was guarded by the kiosk.
- You were smart.
You were smart. I got,
- But its like 108 in Texas, so,
- I got a spattering one
time, it was gardens.
- Oh you did?
- Yeah, it was, not cute.
- Well you have a kid.
Have you ever been peed
on or pooped on or?
- [Channing] Yeah.
- Yip, Yip
- Tons. Tons of time, but
never by a monkey before.
That was, that was
- [Kelly] I never got,
I never got nailed by it
but my kiosk did, but thank you so much.
I love the movie.
- [Channing] Yes. Thank you so much.
- You have to go see it, it's so good.
I'm not kidding.
You literally do feel all the emotions
like while watching it.
It's so good.
And Dog is in theaters tomorrow.
So go check it out.